now let's talk about that next okay is
this Republican Trump tax proposal going
to pass Republicans really need this
proposal to go through Trump desperately
needs the proposal to go through just to
put something on the board that he might
call a legislative accomplishment
repealing Obamacare has failed three
times the travel ban has failed multiple
times building the wall with Mexico that
Mexico is going to pay for I mean that's
laughable at this point right so Trump
needs this and Republican needs it and
one problem kind of a major problem is
that the bill is a disaster right I
already told you earlier in the show how
the bill is going to explode the deficit
it's a hand out to the rich it's an
extra big hand out to the extra rich it
already appears to be delayed though the
goal was get the tax cut program the tax
reform plan through the respective House
and Senate committees conference the
bill come up with a final version that
both the House and Senate agree on vote
on it and pass the thing by the end of
the year the problem is and the LA Times
is a really good story on this the
problem is that the Senate isn't going
to be able to do everything that's in
the bill later today we're expecting the
final Senate version of this bill but
the Senate has this thing this rule it's
a really inconvenient rule that they
have where they can't pass something
that would increase the deficit by more
than 1.3 trillion dollars I'm sorry but
by more than 1.5 actually trillion
dollars over a decade and you might be
saying well hold on a second Republicans
are all about reducing the deficit not
increasing it at all why are they even
considering a tax cut proposal that
would increase the deficit well because
that's what they do right they want to
cut taxes for the rich rich that
increases the deficit as long as it's
not increasing the deficit for social
welfare programs increasing the deficit
is OK for Republicans but the
Republicans in the Senate do have this
issue it's a limit that they're up
against and they're basically going back
to the drawing board one Republican
official said a couple of days ago
everything is on the table everything is
on the table so there's a couple
different things that Senate Republicans
might do to this bill to change it and
get it under the addition of 1.5
trillion to the deficit over ten years
one is they could repeal the state and
local tax deductions federally 100%
right now this is particularly bad for a
high tax state so California is an
example Illinois I actually don't know
where Massachusetts Falls in terms of of
tax compared to other states I assume
it's certainly near the top so that
would directly hurt blue state's
relative to red states because normally
at the federal level you're able to
deduct the taxes that you pay at the
state and local level and pay less in
taxes federally if you're in a state
with higher taxes and you can no longer
deduct those it is disproportionately
going to hit blue Staters for example
that's one thing that Republicans in the
Senate could do to try to reduce the
deficit increasing amount of this
proposal another part would be lower the
income threshold for when you enter the
39.6% bracket the highest tax bracket
federally under this proposal would be
thirty nine point six percent if you
lower the income threshold at which you
start paying thirty nine point six
percent that would reduce the amount
that the proposal would add to the
deficit you could choose to retain parts
of the estate tax in contrast to the
version that's out there right now and
of course Old Faithful is you can try to
repeal parts of Obamacare that cost
money but we we saw how that went a
couple of times already
so eventually the Senate is going to
figure it out and we're probably only
hours from hearing that proposal for the
Senate so why is there going to be a
delay you might be thinking if this can
be dealt with today by the Senate that's
fine move on and vote on it the problem
is that the House Republicans aren't
going to go for it right the House
Republicans want the bill as originally
written and as often is the case and
we've been covering these proposals for
years we'll end up with a conflict
between the sort of more extreme and
ideologically committed House
Republicans
and the marginally less extreme and
slightly more realistic Senate
Republicans who have some more
restrictions on what it is they can get
away with I'm actually kind of split on
this bill because on the one hand this
would be a great bill for me right it
would increase the standard deduction I
usually take the standard deduction
rather than itemizing my deductions it
would reduce income tax on pass-through
business entities the david pakman show
is an s-corporation
I'm an owner of that S corporation so
reducing the tax rate on pass-through
income would be really really good for
me so that that's on the one hand on the
other hand it's a completely immoral
handout to people who not only don't
deserve this but it won't stimulate the
economy to give these people more money
so I'm really torn I'm just kidding I'm
not actually torn although I would
benefit from this I'm against it I'm
absolutely against it I think it is
utterly terrible and it also contradicts
what Republicans say matters which is
not increasing the deficit it
contradicts what Trump himself said he
would do which is mostly help the middle
class and that his rich friends were
going to be angry with him turns out his
rich friends love it turns out that the
richest members of trumps own cabinet
and staff would save billions of dollars
as a result of the changes to the estate
tax so no even though I would benefit
from this I don't think it's the right
proposal I am against it and I'm curious
to hear from you I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blue Sky binaries blockchain Academy
blockchain is the latest trend in
technology and the Internet
many people unaware of the power of
blockchain unaware of the risks carried
by blockchain technology some people
think it's too complicated to get into
and so they are staying away and missing
out on both knowledge and opportunities
within the blockchain world but it
really doesn't have to be this way and
the solution is the blue sky binary
blockchain Academy blue sky binary is a
leading financial education and
technology company and they're focused
on foreign exchange but are turning
their focus to blockchain and the blue
sky binary blockchain Academy can
complement the successful training
Kadim ii complete completion it's great
for both beginners within the blockchain
world as well as active crypto users and
within the course students are taken
through a series of topics which
ultimately will deliver a solid
understanding of how blockchain works it
will help the students realize the
current and potential uses of blockchain
technology which we've covered on the
program before and the course includes
video on-demand online tests access to a
community of traders and blockchain
enthusiasts who exchange both knowledge
and experiences and our viewers and
listeners at blueSky binary.com
/ David can register now to get a 3 day
free trial which includes access to the
first module of the blockchain academy
course you can evaluate it decide if
it's right for you stick with it or
cancel anytime and resume whenever you
want to once again get that 3 day free
trial of the blockchain academy at blue
sky binary.com / David